mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
this problem was given in a cambridge
exam in the year 1801.
evaluate the following alternating
series
the first term is one divided by one
multiplied by three
then we subtract one divided by two
multiplied by four
then we add one divided by three
multiplied by five
then we subtract one divided by four
multiplied by six
and the pattern continues indefinitely
what is the value of this sum
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to evaluate this sum we will first
notice a pattern
in each of the terms each of the terms
has the form
of one divided by n multiplied by n
plus two we will further simplify this
fraction
into its partial fraction decomposition
this fraction will be equal to some
number divided by
n plus another number divided by n
plus 2. we need to solve for the values
of
a and b to do that we'll multiply both
sides of this equation
by n multiplied by n plus 2.
we will then distribute this in the
first term
the n terms will cancel out in the
second term
the n plus 2s will cancel out
we will now distribute the a and then we
will group
the n's so we have 1 is equal to 2a plus
n multiplied by a plus b notice that 1
is equal to 1 plus n times 0.
we will now equate the constant
coefficients
we need 2a to be equal to one which
means
a is equal to one-half we will now
equate the coefficients on
n we want a plus b to be equal to zero
but we know that a is equal to one-half
therefore b is equal to negative one
half
we've now solved for the values of a and
b so let's substitute them in
we will further simplify that negative
one-half
we can just subtract the second term and
make it one half divided
by n plus two with our partial fraction
decomposition we can proceed
we will now solve the problem
let's take the partial sum up to k terms
where k is greater than four
we will then use the partial fraction
decomposition on each term
so the first term will become one half
over one minus
one half over three we'll use the
partial
fraction decomposition for the second
term but we need to subtract
so in this case the signs will be
reversed we need to subtract
one-half over two and then add one-half
over four
we'll continue substituting for each of
the terms in this alternating series
we'll make one more step that we will
substitute for the k minus 1 term
we now substitute in for the final term
this looks very complicated but it will
all magically simplify
notice that this negative one-half over
three and this plus one-half over three
will cancel out then if we advance by
two terms
we will see that one-half over four and
negative one-half over four
will cancel out again if we advance by
two terms
these two terms will cancel out and this
will actually happen
as we advance two terms in all of these
terms in the middle part of the series
these terms will also cancel out and
these terms will also cancel out
we only have the top two terms with
denominators of k plus one and k plus
two which will survive
this type of series where we have only
the very beginning
and the very end survive is known as the
telescoping series
and it's similar to how their tubes of a
retracted telescope will collapse upon
themselves
so all of these terms will vanish and
just these four terms will remain
from here let's consider the behavior as
k goes to infinity
in this term as k goes to infinity the
denominator will get larger and larger
so the term will eventually go to zero
the same thing is true for this term
here as k goes to infinity
this term will go to zero so the limit
as k goes to infinity
of this sum will be equal to one half
over one minus one half over two minus
zero
minus zero therefore the final two terms
will vanish
and we just have one half over one minus
one half over two
which is equal to one half minus one
over four
and that's equal to one over four and
that's the answer
what an interesting alternating series
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time